this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to another episode of biographics I'm
your host KY Smallwood if you don't
believe me that's my real name and you
see it on social media at the links
below and today we're talking about
William Stevenson the Intrepid spy
master who inspired James Bond and as
with all the videos on our Channel this
one is based on original article
submitted by our army of writers this
one being Radu Alexander if you like the
sound of that name you can follow them
on social media if they provided the
links below but let's get to
it when people ask what you do for a
living there are a few answers you could
give that would sound more impressive
than spy Master you know YouTube host
doesn't really have the same gravitas
does it but that was essentially what
William Stevenson did during World War
II is he was absolutely instrumental in
establishing the UK's intelligence
Network in North America and creating a
tight-knit relationship between numerous
different agencies from both sides of
the Atlantic and as if that wasn't good
enough he also had a badass code name
Intrepid and sure Stevenson was crucial
to Britain's comeback success in the war
but it's the really cool title and
nickname that we want to talk about
today in addition to all the other stuff
I did to add to his many accolay
Stevenson is known as being among the
people to have served as an inspiration
for the most famous fictional spy in the
world 007 because one of the many agents
who worked alongside him was none other
than Ian Fleming who once wrote James
Bond is a highly romanized version of a
true spy the real thing is William
Stevenson but we're getting ahead of
ourselves William Samuel Stevenson was
actually born William Samuel Clon
Stanger or Stanger I looked up multiple
pronunciation guys on this one none of
them seem quite clear on what the
pronunciation of his last name is in
Winnipeg Manitoba Canada on January 11th
or 23rd 1897 quite fitting for a spy we
don't know the exact day he was born the
records were a bit hazy like you know
around this time period so forgive us
for any details we get wrong but just
think of it as just you know a bit of
extra meta World building for a guy who
would become known as the Spy master of
World War II the second of four children
to William and Sarah Stanger a Scottish
and Icelandic immigrant respectively
although their eldest died in infancy
Williams time with his birth parents was
depressingly brief in 1901 his father
died of progressive muscular atrophy a
condition exacerbated by a lifetime of
grueling hard labor his mother was left
to raise three children on the pittance
that she earned as a Char woman or you
know pism for a cleaner she turned to
help from one of her friends another
Icelandic immigrant named Kristen
Stevenson who lived in a house in point
Douglas alongside her husband and this
is a name vigus and their children and
she offered to take in William and raise
him as one of her own it's unclear what
became of Sarah Stanger and all other
children from that point on but young
William was adopted by vigus and Kristen
and became known as William Stevenson
life with the Stevenson was pleasant but
not exactly easy all of William's
adoptive siblings had to find jobs to
support the family and eventually so did
he he left school after finishing the
sixth grade and began working at a
Lumberyard later switching to position
as a telegram delivery boy William was
still with the Great Northwest Telegraph
company in 1914 when World War I started
two years later he decided that he
didn't want to just stand idly by as the
rest of the world fought so he enlisted
with the 101st Battalion Winnipeg light
infantry and got sent to a training camp
a few months later he was headed for
Britain aboard the SS Olympic and from
then on to France unfortunately for
Stevenson his time in the trenchers were
not only shortlived but it almost got
him killed less than a week after
arriving in France he was wounded and
gassed in combat he survived but had to
be set back to England for convalescence
Stevenson needed a whole year to get
back on his feet but he put that time to
good use he took courses at ex College
on Wireless Communications Aeronautics
navigation and internal combustion
engines which were a new fangled thing
at the time he got back into shape by
canoeing and boxing in regards to the
latter Stevenson had actually been quite
passionate about pugilism for several
years but now had an opportunity to
practice it competitively um in the
featherweight class and even won a
championship in the inter Allied games
he also became good friends with another
Boxer a Bly American by the name of Jean
Tony who would go on to become the world
heavyweight champ when he was TR to get
back to action Stevenson wanted to
become a pilot so he joined the cadet
wing of the royal flying Corp by 1918 he
was ready to return to France this time
as part of the RAF suffice to say that
Stevenson excelled as a pilot he became
a flying ace and earned several medals
Downing anywhere between 12 and 26 enemy
aircraft depending on who you ask but
you know the old saying some days you're
the windshield other days you do the
book being a pilot during World War I
was one of the most dangerous jobs in
the world and inevitably someone else
had Stevenson's number in July 19 his
plane got hit and went down in enemy
territory Stevenson survived the crash
but was captured and sent to a prisoner
of war camp in I hope I pronounced this
word correctly HS Minden his time as a p
is poorly documented Stevenson said that
he and his fellow prisoners would while
away the hours holding competitions to
see who could steal the most stuff from
German prison officers he managed to
escape the camp in October 198 shortly
before the war ended and he would have
been released Anyway by 1919 he was back
living in
now that the war was over Stevenson
needed to find a way to make a living
eventually he would become a rich and
successful entrepreneur but that success
did not exactly happen overnight his
first Venture was to open a hardware
business called Franco British supplies
clearly you know creativity wasn't one
of his strong suits alongside a friend
named Charles Wilfred Russell
unfortunately the two of them picked a
pretty bad time to start a new company
in Winnipeg as there was a recession
that culminated in a general strike
nobody was looking to buy what Stevenson
was selling so it's a year later the
company fil for bankruptcy now there
were almost a 100 creditors all over
North America looking to recoup some of
their losses Stevenson thought it wise
to make himself scared so soon after the
bankruptcy dat in 1922 he packed his bag
and moved to
England so this is the part of the video
where we talk about our sponsor and
today's sponsor is Squarespace and to
help me work my way through this I've
got off camera Brad Anisha from F and
brisha what do you know about
Squarespace it's an all-in-one website
platform we of course yeah we've we've
all heard that but what is Squarespace
really well it's a website where you can
literally customize anything but what
does that mean you can customize
anything you want car you put anything
on it anywhere do that
[Music]
mean whether you're an amateur or a
business
person just just's just posting through
it just just keep going through the read
it's fine just let him have his fun no
what does that mean Squarespace has this
thing called a fluid engine see that
interests me because I want to know how
you name that because name mean naming
things is so diff What does fluid engine
mean basically you can drag and drop
anything anywhere on the website there's
like no limitations like you would get
on word for example you know I was being
silly and fous earlier but this is a
genuinely useful tool for people who
want to create a website so if you want
a website and you don't want to like do
all the ballach stuff on the back end
this is the tool you like literally like
there's been times where I've wanted to
create websites and I just can't get the
look right because of the limitations
whereas with Squarespace you you could
literally create anything anyhow and you
also as well to get to point you know
think I'm really smart you drag you drag
someone across and you go you know what
I'm a website designer do feel very
impressive when you show website like do
you make it yourself yes I do absolutely
they don't see in in the back of your
head you're like thanks square
space the most valuable thing we all
have get a bit wax for bit philosophical
here it's
time time is the most valuable thing and
anything that allows you to save time is
going to be useful well what about money
call well of course money is also
important if you want to make money you
can do that on Squarespace you can have
one time payments or subscription
services like you can sell your time
like prove the value of your own time by
like you can create courses yes that's
the thing y you create your own courses
on Squarespace you can teach people like
teach people your
skills share them with the world and now
just speaking as a content creator one
of the tools that I think Squarespace
genuinely deserves some praise for it's
just making um analytics front and
center of that advertising campaign
analytics online are King if you're not
keeping track of them you are not using
the internet correctly if you want to
create content you want to monetize your
time your hobbies or just create a
website that shares a passion or
interest of yours tracking who's viewing
that where from and all that good stuff
is an incredibly valuable and important
thing and Squarespace makes it very
simple so thank you to is today's host
Squarespace check out ww.
squarespace.com
biographics for a 10% off on your first
purchase of a website slain using the
code
biographics Stevenson's first company
was a great big flop but it did not
deter him somehow he arrived in England
still flush with cash and he was looking
to invest ever since his days as a
telegram delivery boy Stevenson had
developed an in in radio and wireless
technology so he invested in the general
radio company and Cox Cavendish
Electrical Company Limited and not only
did Stevenson contribute funds but he
was something of a tinkerer in his own
right so despite having no formal
education in electronics he managed to
patent a wireless photography system
that was the precursor to the modern
fact machine in October 1923 Stevenson
was the managing director at a radio
company and even returned to Canada as
its representative to Showcase their
products at various Electronics
exhibitions this Voyage was notable
because on the return ship Stevenson met
a tobacco AIS from Springfield Tennessee
named Mary French Simmons the two fell
in love and got married on July 22nd
1924 some have cast doubt over the true
extent of Stevenson's personal
involvement in his work related to the
transmission of images but assuming his
claims are true which this is a video
about him you know we're going to give
him the benefit of the doubt on this one
his patent turned Stevenson into a
multi-millionaire by the time he turned
30 his wise Fortune probably also didn't
hurt either even so we had no intention
of slowing down so over the following
decade Stevenson kept expanding and
diversifying his business interest he
founded a holding company called British
Pacific trust that invested in a number
of different Industries such as aircraft
manufacturing steel production cement
and real estate Stevenson even got into
the movie business at one point helping
form Sound City films later known as
shepperton Studios Stevenson's business
took him all over the globe including as
mentioned Canada where he still owed
money Mak connections and meeting the
top industrialist inventors Engineers
politicians and financers that the world
had to offer it is unclear when exactly
Stevenson first met Winston Churchill
but the British Statesman and future
Prime Minister will go on to rely
heavily on William Stevenson's skills
and expertise in the tough years that
would follow it was during these
frequent trips to Continental Europe
that Stevenson also became acquainted
with the perilous rise of Nazism as a
prominent businessman with his fingers
in many pies or I guess 10 pies if this
metaphor was taken literal Stevenson met
with a lot of important people and had
access to a lot of sensitive information
it was only natural that he would make
for an enticing Target for British
intelligence to approach just to
convince him to keep his ears open
whenever he traveled abroad and that's
how William Stevenson became a spy
although the exact year is a bit of a
mystery we are talking about Espionage
here it could have been as early as 1936
but as you might expect these people are
pretty big on secrecy and not the kind
to spy and tell so we don't really know
Stevenson himself would approach the
subject very loosely saying in an
interview and I quote we were all
friends you see Churchill and the rest
we were a group of friends who saw the
war coming by 1938 Stevenson had already
become an invaluable although unofficial
asset who was gathering intelligence and
doing research into German reent on a
large scale something that was forbidden
according to the Treaty of vers
Stevenson saw this as a major threat
believing that Britain was to quote him
woefully unprepared for a war with
Germany and so did Churchill although
the latter had trouble convincing
parliament of this fact sure we all know
that hindsight is 2020 but Churchill's
predecessor as prime minister Neville
Chamberlain would forever be remembered
and criticized for his fign policy of
appeasement when it came to Nazi Germany
there is a story from around this time
which is poorly documented even by ESPN
standards and is most likely apical but
we absolutely had to include it since it
involved Stevenson volunteering to
assassinate Hitler so we have to
emphasize the word allegedly here but
we're going to tell the story as it's
recounted in admittedly very very um uh
let's put it
diplomatically hazy sourcer so The Story
Goes that in 1938 Stevenson was
corresponding with his contacts back in
Britain about suggestions for averting
the impending Calamity as he wrote in
his letters Stephenson believed that the
best course of action was for a lone
English sniper to take out Hitler during
a rally not only that but he offered to
be the one to do it and then disavow any
connections to the British government
and accept the consequence of his
actions however the foreign secretary at
the time lord Halifax vetoed any such
measures believing that assassination
should not be used and I quote as a
substitute for diplomacy of course we
all know now that Stevenson's fears were
wholly warranted and later proven
unfortunately correct when Hitler
started invading his neighbors once
World War II was out in full force
Churchill became the new prime minister
of the United Kingdom and began working
closely with America even though it
would be a while before the US would
officially enter the freight President
Roosevelt wanted help from British
intelligences to collect information and
Churchill had just the guy in mind so in
Spring of 1940 Stevenson packed his bags
and went back to New York
City Stevenson's first contact with
America was the director of the FBI at a
time Jay Edgar Hoover allegedly their
introduction was made by his old boxing
pal heavy champ Jean tonny Stevenson's
main objective in America though was to
settle the British security coordination
or be
a covert organization whose goals were
to look after British interests in the
United States counter German propaganda
protect their assets of sabotage and
generally just maintain a good public
opinion that was Pro Britain and
anti-nazi Hoover did want to get on
board but he refused to do so without a
direct order from the White House since
it would be contravening America's
neutrality laws neutrality with Nazis
fortunately he did receive word that
President Roosevelt wanted the closest
possible marriage between the FBI and
British intelligence and so it was that
the BSC opened up its shop at the
Rockefeller Center in Manhattan although
anyone who mistakenly wandered into the
headquarters would find themselves not
inside the headquarters of a spying
organization but the British passport
control office apparently not even
realizing that the people they were
talking to about getting their passport
renewed were spies on the government's
payroll at its height the BSC had just
shy of a thousand members it wasn't just
spies but also journalists and radio
workers who tried to minimize both Nazi
sympathies and support isolationism
which argued that the United States of
America should stay out of the war and
then there were also plenty of officers
and agents who kept open lines of
communications with an ever expanding
network of contacts from other agencies
this included one Ian Fleming who was
working as a naval liaison officer when
he met William Stevenson and clearly saw
in him qualities he thought would make
for an interesting spy character r d
better known as the Beloved children's
author would write Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory and James mag Giant
Peach was also another member of
Stevenson's little spies on Intrepid as
he was now known Stevenson's first major
score as the head of the BSC was helping
to engineer the so-called destroyers for
bases deal from September 1940 I saw
Britain receive 50 destroyers from the
United States without the latter
breaking its neutrality laws one of
Stevenson's closest Associates during
this time in the BC was Bill Donovan an
American lawyer and former soldier who
would serve as the head of the office of
strategic services or USS the precursor
to the CIA Stevenson arranged for
Donovan to take an extended trip to
England to see the situation for himself
this was done through secret channels
and not even the American Embassy in
London knew about it this was probably
for the best since the American
ambassador Joseph Kennedy the father of
JFK was convinced that Britain's defeat
was inevitable and kept advising
Washington to not get involved cheers
for that one Kennedy Donovan needed to
see how things stood after all as much
as he wanted to help the UK he would
advise against it if he thought that
American assets will simply be destroyed
or even worse captured by the Germans
and used against them after a few weeks
in England Don returned home convinced
that the British desperately needed
American help and that they should
provide it Donovan got FDR on board but
the president was still Shackled by the
limitations of America's Neutrality Act
not to mention that he had elections
coming up and didn't want to see him two
pro warar even if that was proar with
the Nazis eventually after enough legal
finagles and loopholes the deal was done
FDR got senior military official to
certify that 50 agent destroyers were
not essential to the defense of the
United States and instead of Simply
providing Aid America made a trade in
exchange for a 99-year lease on British
Naval and air bases and Roosevelt pulled
it off without the need for
Congressional approval of course he
still got a lot of flack from his
political opponents for doing this but
overall it was a crucial deal that did
help ter ATI of the war it represented
only the beginning of the anglo-american
cooperation that was to follow when he
wasn't securing military assets William
Stevenson was looking after Britain's
image in America as we said there were
plenty of interest groups who promoted
isolationist views feeling that this
wasn't America's War and then of course
there were others who were just openly
in favor of Nazi Germany so Stevenson
had BSC agents infiltrate these groups
all over the country to keep tabs on who
was doing what at the same time he was
making powerful allies in the media the
New York Times the New York Post the New
York Herald Tribune and the Baltimore
son were all sympathetic to the British
cause at the very least not big fans of
Nazism at one point the BSC even
subsidized a radio station in New York
called WL and turn it into a Non-Stop
propaganda and recruitment Channel
of course all the propaganda work became
decided less necessary after the United
States officially joined the war in
December 1941 once that happened
Stevenson could redirect his attention
elsewhere and started opening a spy
school in Canada on the shores of Lake
Ontario unofficially known by the
frankly awesome Monica of Camp X this
was the place during the war where
American and Canadian agents trained to
do super secret spy like Espionage
sabotage unarmed combat weapons training
and even silent assassinations it's
worth noting that the agents who trained
here were not protected by the Geneva
Convention due to the Antics and many of
them were captured tortured and indeed
executed by the enemy while those who
survived received no individual
recognition for their efforts in
addition to this the camp had an
advanced secret Communications Network
that they called Hydra seriously which
the Canadians kept using until the late
60s during the Cold War not particularly
relevant but we thought it sounded cool
you know which she do does you know to
find out how you know spies use a
communication Network called Hydra
during the war that's that's pretty rad
nowadays what's left of Camp X is a park
called Intrepid Park in honor of
Stevenson's code name during the war you
might notice at this point other than
Stevenson's early years as a pilot with
the RAF most of his work was done at his
desk or in meetings not quite as many
perilous encounters with evil villains
in secret layers fighting off deadly
henchmen with sharp bowler hats as one
might expect from a super spy certainly
not a super spy who inspired James Bond
certainly no drinking shake and martinis
with sexy ladies with the suggestive
names like Gore or plento tool but
the reality is that we simply don't know
the true extent of intrepids going on
and we probably never will he certainly
traveled a lot and it's not like he had
a 9 to-5 office job during the war he
made over 40 trips to Britain alone but
most of them were confidential and
undocumented made using aliases because
you know spy after the war most of the
BSC records were destroyed and the
people who used to work there know how
to keep a secret again because spy whose
activities still and likely will forever
remain a mystery what we can offer
though is a quick description courtesy
of the head of the UK Special Operations
executive Colin gobbins who considered
Stevenson's actions a series of
brilliant individual coups against Axis
powers in the true traditions of secret
intelligences with modern embellishments
which in fact had an influence on
military operations in the main theaters
we who were in soe are a profound debt
to Stevenson and all those who worked in
cooperation with him in so many VI
aspects of inter Allied achievement not
exactly moon rer but it does hint that
some cool stuff
[Music]
happened even so we still know what
Stevenson did in Broad Strokes we know
for example that he established a
censorship station in Bermuda with the
support of his American counterpart bill
donov it this had over a thousand
sensors Intelligence Officers and C
Breakers who work there during the war
examining every piece of transatlantic
mail for any useful or workable
their biggest success was busting the
so-called Joe K ring led by us-born
German spy Carl ludvik ludvig and his
agents were sending information to
Berlin about Alli ships in New York
Harbor so they could be targeted by
German
OTS at various points during World War
II William Stevenson represented at Hall
or in part the MI5 MI6 the Special
Operations executive the political
intelligence Department the Office of
Naval intelligence the security Council
and the special branch of Scotland Yard
so seven different intelligence agencies
that we know of and in an unusual move
for a spy he received public recognition
for all of his efforts and he was Ned in
1945 as personally recommended by
Winston Churchill who wrote In His
recommendation letter in part this one
is dear to my heart still very few
people know the true extent of his work
the Public Announcement in the newspaper
simply referred to Stevenson as being
employed in a department of the foreign
office the Americans too wanted to show
their appreciation for agent intrepid's
invaluable contributions to the war
effort so they awarded Stevenson the
medal of Merit making him one of the
first foreigners to receive this
particular honor following the war
Stevenson stepped away for some much
needed RNR and bought a little place in
Jamaica he and his wife would often host
fancy dinner parties shindigs and Suarez
where the guest lists were usually a
who's who from the world of
entertainment politics and the media at
large this was his life for about 5
years until Stevenson got bored with his
little island retreat and started
lusting after the big city again so in
1951 the Stevenson sold their house in
Jamaica and moved to New York City where
they lived right above gret Garo in a
lavish apartment that took up an entire
floor of the building as a civilian
again Stephen once again returned to the
world of corporate America but without
as much a plum as he had before he
encouraged development and investment
opportunities in the Caribbean as well
as his native Canadian province of
Manitoba but he suffered a stroke in the
early 60s that slowed him down
considerably after a long grueling
recovery the Stevenson decided screw
this and said goodbye to the business
world forever so they packed up their
bags with final time and moved to
Bermuda they spent the next decade and a
half there in relative Solitude although
the people who came to visit Stevenson's
the ones his previous Life as a spy
master all said that he stayed well
informed on all significant Global
developments he still reportedly had a
tax machine which he used to send and
receive secret Communications from all
over the world well into his Advanced
age whether or not Stevenson's still
moonlighted as Intrepid we can only
speculate late Mary Stevenson was the
first to go dying in 1977 of cancer
since they had no children of their own
William Stevenson adopted his late
wife's nurse Elizabeth as his daughter
he lived for 12 more years dying on
January 31st 1989 at the age of 92 his
funeral like his life was furtive and
Hush Hush as per Stevenson's Last Wishes
his death was announced only after his
funeral had already taken place thus
ensuring only a handful of his closest
friends and family would attend and thus
the life of intrepid ended so thank you
to everyone at home for tuning into this
episode of biographics as mentioned at
the start I've been your host car
Smallwood it's still my real name you
can go look her up on social media
alongside My Links you will find links
to um the author of this piece Ru
Alexander if they provided them for us
in addition to links to my other
channels that I help run fact Fe with
Cal Smallwood and Wiki weekends try
present with a good friend I don't know
why I do this this is a nervous habit
I'm going to start that that's I would
like to ask as well so if you like the
video leave a like if you have uh any
comments you can leave them below
particular I'd like comments about my
hosting and presentation style uh I've
been taking aboard all the feedback
we've received so far or at least the
feedback that's not just I'm not Simon
Whistler I can't help it I'm not as
aerodynamic or as iridite as he is but I
am trying my best so any feedback about
that will be greatly appreciated and I
am trying to improve like I've got new
sound equipment new video equipment been
moving stuff throughout slowly and
behind the scenes um our editors writers
and producers have all been working
their asses off to try and make me sound
as presentable as possible but either
way I appreciate people sticking with us
to this transitionary period thank you
to everyone for watching like comment
subscribe as you've already said and as
always like to wish everyone has the day
that they deserve thank you very much
cheers